hey folks before we get started i wanted
to let you know i have new merch
available if you go to my tee public
store there's a link down in the
description you will find
beautiful valid loved the one you're
seeing on me right now
these are gender fluid pride colors i
have this design available in 16
different pride colors available in a
wide variety of styles and colors for
the shirts you can find something for
yourself
or for a loved one who you want to let
them know that you are proud of them
what me get more worked up about
something than it's worth
don't be silly
[Music]
so yeah i'm going to talk about the
timeless child again because as we near
a new episode of doctor who
uh where things were left off has been
on my mind
and i actually was struck by an
odd question
how much does
the doctor being the timeless child
actually
change things now as i sort of
talk through what i'm thinking what's
sort of been on my mind please keep at
the front of your own minds that
obviously the degree to which this
impacts things
is going to change and evolve as new
episodes addressing it come
out so i am speaking now only from our
current
situation i don't know how this is going
to be integrated into future episodes
neither do you and i'm not here to
speculate on it
i'm just saying that right now
inherently
the way we learned what we learned how
it was implemented and what we know
about things so far
how much will it actually
matter and will it actually have
significant tangible regularly
engaged with consequences beyond
whatever storyline chipnel does
again asterix sing depending on what
that storyline is maybe the answer will
definitely be yes it does
but as of right now because here was the
first thing that i found myself thinking
about
and it's the fact that obviously a lot
of people are
upset at the idea that hartnell is not
in fact
the first doctor and i do get why that
rubs a lot of people the wrong way but i
kind of
reverse engineered why that doesn't
bother me so much
and i realized why it's because of the
mind wipe
it's because of the fact that the doctor
has never known prior to now
that they had any lives before hartnell
well what that means is that this really
has zero impact
on the regeneration and lives of the
doctor that we've already seen
hartnell through the capaldi the
timeless child actually does not affect
those
at all not in any practical terms
again if you are a lorehound it does
affect things in terms of if you're
trying to plot out a chronology and
where
everything lands and stuff like that but
that's all kind of meta elements
that's all stuff that affects fans
but not really these stories
it doesn't recontextualize the lives of
any of these previous incarnations
because it's not like
they knew and we as an audience didn't
know that they knew no they didn't know
either
so they lived their lives self-contained
as we got to
see and witness on the show and in
comics and big finish
and all the other things that's actually
pretty untouched by
the timeless child so that's the first
thing that like
really truly zero impact there there's
also the fact that so far as we could
tell this was not a widely known fact on
gallifrey
either it was something that however
many people knew which was probably not
many was something that they tried to
keep a lid on
so maybe it recontextualizes i don't
know
the high council who's already been
recontextualized repeatedly over the
history of this show
but other than that it doesn't actually
directly impact all that many characters
that we've already seen
at least in terms of altering the things
we already knew or the things we've
already seen them
do so that then brings the question
how much will this impact things going
forward and that of course
is the big open question it's one i'm
not in a position to answer
but i do think that just the inclusion
of
the memory wipe and the fact that the
doctor doesn't remember any of this
has the potential that as lore shaking
as this
feels it has the potential to ultimately
mean
very little if after chidnal's done with
it he moves on to other things or
whatever showrunner
comes after doesn't want to touch it
it actually doesn't really impact
anybody other than this incarnation of
the master
and this incarnation of the doctor and
it's not a given that it has to impact
anybody else after that
now beyond potential impact on the
doctor i suppose the
i would say most interesting but also
thing that i'm more most nervous about
that it
could potentially do it opens up a
window that we haven't had before which
is the possibility that
we could have at some point as a
spin-off show or even
after whitaker instead of moving past
and going to the next chronological
incarnation
we actually get time with an earlier one
if they wanted to explore the ruth
doctor joe martin's doctor
they could feasibly have the doctor
regenerate into her or they could just
decide to do
a few series focusing on her wherever
the heck she fits
into the doctor's timeline and while
that's a possibility
one i'm not entirely sure how i feel
about that because it feels needlessly
fiddly like i don't know necessarily
what the benefit would be
giving us a doctor a series of a doctor
who came earlier
and before hartnell as opposed to
something that would come after whitaker
because i i just don't know why you
would need to do that as opposed to keep
moving forward i always get very
cautious when any franchise gets overly
enamored with
history instead of progressing forward
so that does exist as an option
i'd kind of be surprised if they
actually pulled the trigger on
it's not impossible they might but i'm
just looking at the fact that say
after night of the doctor there was a
lot of call among the fandom for
if not a series or spin off at least a
special or two
of paul mcgann as the eighth doctor
and that never moved and if they were
ever gonna pull the trigger on some sort
of
side series or taking a year and dealing
with
uh like an older version of the doctor
then
whoever is the current one quote unquote
then he would have been the one to go
with because he's got an established fan
base so it would have been way less of a
risk to do it with him so if they didn't
do it for him
i am kind of iffy about whether they
would actually ever
give us more than a flashback
an episode of specific incarnations
preheartenal
because it just kind of makes things
messy again not knowing exactly what
chibnall is planning to do when we
eventually get to series 13.
i've seen people say that this opens up
the possibility of like trying to find
out where the doctor came from whatever
other dimension or whatever and yeah
that's true except that
you don't need that hook for the doctor
to explore
other dimensions i mean if you wanted to
go that direction
you could have had a companion who
seemed to be from some kind of other
dimension or any number of things you
don't need
to make the doctor come from somewhere
other than what we understand this
universe to be in order to be able to
explore that and do that so while yes
that's now a possibility it's not like
that's something that couldn't have been
done
without introducing the whole concept of
the timeless child i suppose in theory
it makes it more personal for the doctor
but again we're gonna have to wait and
see how
this plays out to know whether or not
that's really gonna be in play or not
so the incarnations prior to jody would
occur
they're not really impacted by this
characters outside of gallifrey aren't
impacted by this
at all even on gallifrey like
maybe the high council maybe rasalon
maybe omega if they ever bring him back
and but that's debatable and it's not
really something you need to delve into
more than already was
it seems to me that the only things that
truly have been impacted so far
and i would say the only things worth
exploring really
are the impact of this on the doctor and
the master
and again we don't know what those
impacts will be or how that's going to
play out
but i come back to what i said before
there actually isn't any reason
once you've explored those things with
jody whitaker's doctor and sasha dewan's
master
there's no reason for that to keep
coming up
at this point i'm really starting to
suspect that this entire story
is just going to be the story for
this incarnation of these two characters
it'll impact them and come the next
regeneration
it'll be something else and i'll admit
maybe part of the reason that i'm
talking myself into this is to
be less frustrated because i don't like
being annoyed i don't like being mad
about a show that i really like
and also let me be clear whether this
ultimately
matters all that much or not i still
don't like it i'll
probably never like it i'd be surprised
if i ever come around on that
but it does sort of help me to calm down
a bit
by stopping and thinking okay
yeah it's not good but is it
truly gonna matter all that much in the
grand scheme
and i'm actually starting to lean
towards the idea that no not
really not all that much
and i think i'm kind of okay with that
given that it's a twist i didn't enjoy
i don't know i don't know if this was
helpful for anybody if anybody could
even follow my
logic and thought process on that again
this is kind of me
publicly processing a little bit
it's december you know i've got i've got
a lot going on in my head and sometimes
i just gotta work through it to get some
of it out
so i can do other things so whatever
your thoughts are on this
drop them on down in the comments be
polite to me and to the people involved
in this show no personal attacks
remember that but whatever your thoughts
are drop them down in the comments let's
talk about usual stuff like share
subscribe i have a patreon if you like
what i do and you want to support me
that is in fact
what pays my bills and how i make my
living but even if you don't
all the other things i mentioned that
they help i have links to merch besides
um and all the usual things but you also
don't have to because
at the end of the day you're the council
i just run the meetings and until next
time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]